we're just just asking him about the
first time he asked her girl out I don't
know why I thought oh yeah she not great
she said yes yeah yeah pretty good she
said yes but he just made a fool out of
himself dancing properly yeah yeah
you're handsome do we only know I'm a
[ __ ] mongrel
no you're a handsome guy we all the
great before you came in we were all
swooning
you know maybe we're you handsome before
you were famous or what you got famous
then did you become handsome you know
looking at when I first started my my
career in Hollywood we had to be on
camera you know I would go people often
compliment me on my my choice of you
know being in serious projects my choice
of the director but that's all [ __ ]
i I absolutely tried to be in rom-coms
and so by they looked at my big-ass nose
my giant ears and they're like we want
no part of you in this world I literally
casting directors would like shut shut
away in [ __ ] horror of my face you
know so how do i phrase it then they
actually tell you that or do they say
something else clear it's so clear by
you walk in the room and and and you
know first all you're in the waiting
room it's like the prettiest dudes
you've ever seen in your life and then
when you walk in it's just like you know
they look at you in that you know
unconsciously like touching their nose
while you're talking and and you look
you know eventually looking back I'm
grateful for it you know I'm grateful
for I'm grateful that you know that that
wasn't the way the direction my career
went but yeah it was definitely it
definitely hurt the feelings you're
promoting The Punisher it's a 13-episode
season season once exclusively on
Netflix starting November the 17th and
you guys had to cancel your panel at New
York comic-con because of the whole bag
is shooting when you hear something like
that as a performer are you like yeah I
think they should have really like ah
like they're disconnected I was I was
the person who called him suggested well
you were 100% man I think you know I
mean look the the whole way that the
show was going to be unveiled was you
know there was we sort of weren't
revealing the release date and what we
were going to do is that New York
comic-con I was going to come on stage
and say the show is available right now
we're gonna make sort of a story out of
it and I thought you know at the time at
the time to try to make a news story and
try to sort of divert any attention away
from what was going on I thought was
disrespectful and something I really
wanted no part of okay I think the
tragedy I mean the tragedies just keep
[ __ ] coming but I can't begin to
explain to you what it was like you know
we premiered last night the night before
you know hearing about this this coward
in in in in Texas and this tragedy
that's just you know taking over this
this this town and my heart's [ __ ]
broken man I mean my heart is broken and
you know I I think if anything I think
it has nothing to do with the show the
only the only residence it has for me
regarding the show is that we put this
thing off because of a tragedy and then
here the night before we premiere
there's another one and and I think that
it is time to start addressing the fact
that there's a big [ __ ] problem and
we need to start talking about it I
think we need to stop confusing rigor
with your position being completely
steadfast in your position on on guns
with strength I think we got to start
hearing sense from both sides because
both sides make sense and I think just
being sort of fanatical about this he's
gonna keep us from ever solving any of
these problems do you resent to as an
actor as a performer when people go oh
you're in Hollywood just [ __ ] act and
that's your job and they hate when you
weigh in with opinions look man I'll be
honest with you I kind of when I hear
actors you sort of like present their
their political it oftentimes I want to
say shut the [ __ ] up to be honest with
you because to me yes you're an actor
but why in the world are you in any
position to sort of have an opinion you
know why not not to have an opinion but
why would you think that your opinion
matters more than someone else and I I
feel like a lot of that stuff just sort
of gets sort of just swept away with
with the rest of the stuff and and and I
think that
look I've been if someone's gonna ask me
I'll be vocal and I'll tell you my
opinion but I I think with this show and
and the way that this show is affecting
people in the subject matter of the show
people have been asking me so I'll tell
them and I'm sure people as a guy you
see me very conscientious and very
comfortable talking about speaking your
mind and you did baby driver with Spacey
and then all this stuff happens
obviously
no signs when that's happening but do
you look back oh yeah that was a little
help man I remember being on that set I
remember him really rubbing me the wrong
way
you know and I and and I it's funny
anybody who you know I I was working
with at the time and people in my life
remember me saying it a lot of people
reached out to me you know when that
happened and I think for me you got to
understand you know I started out in
this in this thing you know I was a
theatre actor and when I was a young man
I got to go to London and was a crazy
opportunity for me and the first thing
that I did when I was in London I went
and saw the Iceman Cometh starring Kevin
Spacey you know four-and-a-half-hour
play with him right there and I was
sitting in the front row looking with my
neck straight up and I remember when
that play was over I just jumped up and
gave a standing ovation which is
something I guess they don't [ __ ] do
in London or something because he looked
right at me and he he it was an
unbelievably sort of like transformative
experience in my life watching what he
did and he was one of my favorite actors
you know going on to that set you know
and and and and and working with him I
wasn't there much and I I wasn't really
in a situation to judge but when I was
there he really rubbed me the wrong way
I I thought he was a bit of a bully I
thought he was I thought that he I
didn't really care for the way he was
behaving toward some of the other people
and said and sexually or aggressive I
think I think a combination I think a
combination I think he was he was I you
know I think he was you know acting
towards people in a way that I remember
at the time thinking man if that was if
that was a woman that he was talking to
you know I would I would have I would
have done something I would have said
something and I was really happy to sort
of get out of there and and and and I
remember you know for it for that reason
and I just remember losing a ton of
respect for him and nowhere did I see
anything like some of the allegations
that have come up against him and I
think it's it would be weak and and and
me and of me to sort of like pile on
about some [ __ ] that I don't know about
right but the kind of man he was when I
saw him working with him made me lose
all respect for him and I was enormous
ly disappointed it kind of is amazing
though that like in the last year all
these big projects that you're doing
end up somehow getting attached to these
big other stories stories yeah
it's also kind of weird that I mean
these like there's all these great
people that have kind of come under fire
like artists I mean not if people
obviously but like Woody Allen I'm in
New York Jew it's a part of my life and
now is like can you separate kind of
that do you let it go you know look man
it's tough because you know right now
everybody's got a voice and and and it's
so easy to sort of it's so easy to have
your voice heard there's great things
about that and there's negative parts
about it as well you know and the fact
of the matter is if you behave like a
monster
you know I nowadays like you're gonna
get called out for that [ __ ] and and you
should and you [ __ ] [ __ ] man and and
like times need to change with that
stuff and and and you know it's like
look man there's one thing in the world
I [ __ ] hate it's a bully and and and I
think that you know people have been
getting away with a [ __ ] for too long
it's funny we were just talking about it
before I did Howard this morning and and
you know we were talking about in the
green room about different people and
like everyone's so scared and you know
somebody made a really good comment like
the people were scared probably have
good [ __ ] reason to be scared you
know and and you you know I I think that
I thought I think I think the thing that
we have to watch for is it's an industry
where people want to bring attention to
themselves you know I mean and so I
think that we've got to be you know I
think that we've got to just be III
think we've just got to be hesitant
again and this is why I'm a little bit
hesitant like when you asked me about
Spacey you know like I don't want to
pile on sure a pile on that's what I saw
that's how it affected me and that's
that's what I do okay I think I like the
you don't I like because you came to
only speaking about what you've seen and
because people how could all this stuff
go unnoticed or untalked about but on
what is the dynamic on a set when
there's a a star and the star is a
little difficult to like you said maybe
a little bit bullying and no one's gonna
walk up and go hey shut the [ __ ] up
you're being what is the dynamic of that
when the star is being difficult or a
bully to people you know man you know
like for everything is different and and
and and you know look at the end of the
day you know you it's an artistic
endeavor right it's it's it's it's
you're there to make something you know
you're there to make something and every
director has a different method and
every director let's the the atmosphere
this
that sort of go in many different ways
and I have been in situations where I
think that if you looked at what we were
actually doing right then if you looked
at what the cast and the crew were doing
on set you would be like holy [ __ ] this
is dangerous
this is chaotic this is unsavory you
know but it's exactly essential what we
needed to make the moment that we were
making right you know if you if you
looked at the the orgy scenes in in wolf
of wallstreet you know I I'm sure that
you know if you just looked at that in a
bubble you'd be like what the [ __ ] were
those guys it was crazy
experience but that's what we needed to
do that being said there was no
disrespect
everybody everybody treated each other
professionally everybody you know there
was zero tolerance for people sort of
lording power over other people and you
know III think that I really do think
that those days of that kind of behavior
are going to end because of all this I
really do think yeah I think you're
right did anyone warn you like about
space here was there kind of word out
there that he's kind of a creep or he's
an [ __ ] like I heard I mean not
really I mean I I had heard stories you
know I I had heard stories but you know
to me it's like you know I'm there to go
do a job yeah I mean I'm there to go do
a job and and and like you know man I'm
not gonna [ __ ] you I walked onto
that set and I'm just like I got immense
respect for this guy he's one of my
favorite actors you know he's yeah
enormous ly talented so that's what I
walked in with and you know it didn't
take a long time for me how long until
he like it didn't take me long it's
weird because you almost do when someone
is that good at something you almost
don't want to believe it you know
there's like a partier but I mean I had
a certain point it becomes undeniable
yes I think the majority of the people
that I've gotten to work with it meet in
this profession like they're good people
they're good they're confident they're
solid people I think that you know to be
good at this thing like it takes a level
of empathy where you're open to people
you don't judge them for you know their
race or religion their sexual
orientation you celebrate the
differences in people I think that's all
sort of like part of the the gig and and
if you're not innately that way I don't
think you're going to be a great actor
you know and and so the majority of the
people I meet who are who are
people that I really admire have turned
out to be great people in real life too
and and you know when I think about De
Niro or DiCaprio or Brad Pitt you know
these these guys are heroes of mine then
I go and meet him work with him I only
love them more yeah does that make it
like inexcusable when you see it
happening like when you meet a guy like
Scorsese did you get along with Scorsese
she's the best so when you meet Scorsese
right and you're like that's an awesome
dude
mmm is it almost like if that dude can
be an awesome dude anybody nobody
nobody's got me yeah yeah and-and-and
and look there I think that there's a
you know for somebody like me there I
come in with a level of reverence and
respect you know these guys had like
enormous if it you know Scorsese man
yeah had enormous effect on my life you
know he's shaped so much of what I feel
and what I do when I care about and so
you go in but you know there's you know
anytime somebody comes towards you with
respect
you got wanted to you got it's only you
go one way or the other right you can
either [ __ ] on that person and treat
them like dirt or you can you you can
welcome them in it's it's one way or the
other and to me you know most people who
are confident and and and successful and
and have some level of peace of mind you
know and and and for the most part I
think that if you're really good at
something you don't have it's like you
you've given all that other [ __ ] up you
don't have to lord over somebody who's
in a less powerful position than you
well John is promoting The Punisher 13
episodes season 1 is exclusively on
Netflix November the 17th you had to be
a pretty big prick that pissed off
Scorsese oh he's such a nice guy and
like and who would come at him with his
shitty attitude I mean Marty's just a
fun guy he's speaking with familiarity
just to be an [ __ ] when you were
doing baby driver mmm because I love
that okay
did you uh do you realize what you were
doing because it seems like one of those
movies that was made almost outside of
the camera if that makes sense like so
much of it is in the editing and the
music and just like it's so stylistic do
you know when you're shooting it what
this thing is gonna be no
but you do know with Edgar right Edgar
Wright is a genius like no question that
yeah is a [ __ ] genius and I am no
doubt from the beginning that he knew
exactly what that movie was supposed to
be frame by frame so you might I mean I
can't I signed up for that movie and I
thought I was gonna be there nine days I
kept going back and coming back and
coming back because that opening car
sequence was so unbelievably intricate
and it might just be getting out and
shutting the door over and over and over
again but you have total faith in this
brilliant genius filmmaker that he's
doing everything he's doing for a reason
and in a way it takes a lot of the
pressure off of yours like he will tell
you exactly what he needs he'll tell you
what beats it and and it's almost like
being like a like a uber marionette you
know it's like it you you you believe in
it and that and I think if you sign up
for a film with director like that you
have full faith full confidence and you
know he's going to deliver and he did is
there have you ever been in a position
where you've got a shitty director
that's trying to guess puppeteer you I
mean here's the thing I mean
unfortunately in in unfortunately I
think a lot of the time there's a direct
correlation between the oh sorry I
there's a direct correlation between
look I've been really really lucky with
a lot of the directors that I've gotten
to work with and and enormous ly blessed
and I think that you know there's one
thing that's uniformed and all them
everybody has different methods
everybody has different methodologies
that's the same [ __ ] thing everybody
I think that there's one thing that's
uniform and that is the best ones are
completely collaborative they're
completely open to everyone else's ideas
they're not sitting there there's they
may have ego but they're not led by it
they're not sitting there being like it
has to be this way it's like completely
unbendable and unopened to hearing other
people's ideas the good ones are all it
doesn't matter where the idea comes from
and they all have this ability to make
everyone on set feel like they're 100
feet tall and that and that you can
explore and if you can if you can create
an atmosphere on set well you really
don't know what the [ __ ] is going to
happen and anything can happen
when I think real magic comes and I
think for me it's been almost every time
when someone is not open to that the
project isn't as good they're not as
good and if they're so locked in with
their own vision of what it is it often
mean it's often for me sort of it reeks
of them not being that talented and how
would you have felt sorry to buy usually
the guys like the the
directors who are collaborative how
would you dealt with a guy like a
Stanley Kubrick who was a guy who was
known just to be completely like he had
his vision and that was it parents work
and I think another guy right who's just
like a word-for-word
yeah in word-for-word is fine I mean I
think like then there's also there's a
level like what I said about Edgar a guy
who like this thing like I remember when
when I worked with Polanski you know he
knew everybody's lines he knew he knew
what every frame of that movie was
supposed to be and look I think there
comes a certain point look if you're you
know directing you know you know the
third episode of like some you know 26
episode TV show and you're like no you
have to do it like that you have to
that's a problem if you're Roman
Polanski or Edgar Wright or if you you
know if you that's a little bit
different or Kubrick you know these guys
are visionaries and and you have to fit
into their vision I would imagine though
that within the rigor of that structure
within the how rigid that is there's
full exploration within their you know
once you're in that and that's what my
experience was with Polanski do you do
you think that he has gotten a pass
consider Roman Polanski from from
Hollywood considering the flack that
there that other guys have gotten well
he had to move right but I mean from
Hollywood yeah he's still he's still
active question man III think number one
I think you know the woman the woman who
the charges were about has forgiven him
which which i think is which I think
makes which I think counts for something
okay
has he been I think some have given him
a pass some haven't he's a guy who and
again I I'm not making excuses for him
but he's a guy who suffered unbelievable
trauma in his life and you know you you
you know having his his his pregnant
wife you know butchered in the way that
she was you know I you know
I just can't I can't even like imagine
what that is so you know if that if that
has played into potentially giving him a
pass that's possible I think that look
it was a different time so there's not
this just unbelievable wave of a voice
because people didn't have a voice back
then and so I think honestly you would
be wrong to give him a pass because you
there's no way we can know exactly what
happened and right now you hear scandal
you you hear charge come out about a
certain person of power or certain
celebrity and then it's backed up by
like 15 more people it's like [ __ ] dude
you're not giving that person a pass
it's not about five more to come out
Platt but I get it right after you
walked him he should about five more
come out one girl saying molester when
she was ten again it's I don't know how
true any of it is but like five more
people there was a Twitter mob now that
just takes over and it's not just people
coming out but it's like it almost like
there's like a mob mentality that
dictates what happens to the person in a
way yeah and look man again I think I
think it's a crazy world there's there's
there's there's strengths and weaknesses
to that you know I mean and it's like
this has been going on it's a real thing
and it's it's there are monsters out
there and and they need to be dealt with
and if you you know if if there's people
if there's if there's a ways and means
for people to voice this and and and
stop this like that is only a good thing
did you have to do anything personally
to like was that a struggle that you had
did you have to justify to yourself
should I be working with this guy based
on his history or not rolling voice that
was a really really long time ago and I
think you know you know at the time at
the time it was not you know at the time
it was it was it was like you know it
was so early on in my career you know I
was just kind of kind of thrilled that
he had called you know what I mean and
you know that's just an honest answer
sure yeah yeah yeah a lot of times I
mean you're trying to make it and you
know a giant director you're not going
into all the nuances of the person's
life from Brody you just you can't get
it afford to pull a morality play or
something and go like like you can't
turn that down at that point yeah I mean
look it at a certain point depends on
depends on how much you know about it
depends on what you know about your
hands on
how you know and what exactly that
person did yeah I think everybody has a
you know I I think I was a much
different person than to you know wasn't
a father I was a I just was a much
different person then and I think I was
sort of all about the art and I think
that there's a there's many other things
that are super important now well it's
what I was gonna answer real quick was
it scary when you fer cuz I feel like
you leaving the walking dead as great as
you are in the walking dead
is the best thing that could have
happened to you because you've done so
many awesome things since then was it a
scary thing when you find out if you
know your character gets killed off felt
like you decided to leave like when
you're such like a central character and
that's the I think one of the first
things that that many people could
identify a character that you played
like I know him from The Walking Dead is
it a scary thing - yes scary man I mean
look you know you you you scrape and
claw and and and and you're just trying
to do this thing I less the only thing I
know how to do you know like I love it I
if I if I can't do this I'm screwed man
and and like you know you finally get on
a show you know it's it's it's it's a
tie me people talk about look all
professions are tough this is a tough
profession because there's no rhyme or
reason to it you know you can get
yourself a gig and just getting the gig
is so hard but having the gig actual air
is even harder and then having the gate
actually air and then be successful it's
like all the [ __ ] has to fall into place
it was the first time I had ever been a
part of something in a major way where
that happened and it really blew up and
the second it blows up I got to leave it
and so like yeah right it's like really
scary and you think you got to sort of
stare yourself in the in the mirrors
being like you know really young man and
be like look this is probably gonna be
the pinnacle like you got to be honest
like you you probably never gonna get
here again and and and and I think you
got one of two choices you can either
sort of like stop [ __ ] whining and
and and and and be all sorry for
yourself you know or you can say like
I'm so grateful that I got this
opportunity and I'm so grateful and
looking in hindsight now I wish I could
sort of shake that guy and be like you
put that work out there you made these
amazing relationships you got to create
this awesome character and like let's
look at all the cool [ __ ] you're gonna
get to do afternoon what ya about yeah
did you think you know you think every
jobs your last job I had a job I
literally left the set of The Walking
Dead and I went right into a movie it
was the biggest
job that I had up to date I was still
Worf I'd I still feel well after the
movie it's all over I went right into
something you know and and and you know
looking back on it
you know I there's nothing in my career
I'm more grateful for than The Walking
Dead besides the fact that I got killed
off The Walking Dead
yeah it's literally the best thing to
happen in my career they've also asked a
chance to ask us to promote what is
sweet Virginia that also opens November
the 17th and select theaters and they're
asking us to plug that what is it thank
you for thank you for that man look
sweet Virginia as a film it's it's I'm
ridiculously proud of this film
you know I it's a it's a throwback to
seventies films it's a kid named
Christopher Abbott who's in this film
who's gonna blow you the [ __ ] away I
mean it's like he plays this just
psychotic killer and it reminds me of
the old days when you would go to the
theater to just go see an amazing
performance of De Niro Pacino it reminds
me of Javier Bardem in no country this
guy he is absolutely horrifying but
there's no bravado there's no bluster
there's no tough talk
he's just horrifying and tragic at the
same time and it's really just a
beautifully made tense film and it does
it really reminds me of like the heyday
of film and nowadays that's a it's a
really hard thing to do everybody wants
it here and again I'm talking talking
from a guy who does a super hero things
you know but it's like right now it's
all big tempo movies and sure these are
the kind of movies that need support and
I absolutely guarantee anybody who goes
and sees that movie is gonna be very
very happy with it and you're gonna be
blown away with this guy's performance
well select cities I'm gonna guess New
York or select theaters so many guests
in New York LA maybe a couple of other
just look for sweet Virginia it opens it
it's actually easy to remember cuz the
same day the punisher season one is on
netflix so you got a couple of things
coming up the same day you're having a
better november than most people that's
got to feel good like alright i got
these two huge things coming out at
least you know you're good through the
end of the year you know what's funny
man i don't worry the way that i that i
used to worry i you know i I'm really
grateful
I'm really really grateful and I can't
believe that this is is my life and like
I got three little kids I got a wife
that I love with all my heart you know
that's that's the only place that I
really really want to be a need to be
and
and for me I've just I I can't believe
this and and I got peace men to wrap up
this is there any part of you it's like
okay Punisher comes out 13 episodes drop
right here this head netflix does it
that goes like I kind of wish we were
doing this week by week because then
I've got 13 weeks of like its Punisher
time as opposed to no no no part of me
that no you know that isn't never cross
my mind I think I think that that model
of making a 13 hour movie it helps me so
much in the way that we make it I think
that you know when you make episodic TV
you got to spend the last 10 minutes of
every episode sort of prepping them for
the next week in the first 10 minutes of
every episode saying hey this is what we
did and it's just a [ __ ] way to make
to do it and I think that you know we do
is it gives me the right to not give a
[ __ ] whether the audience likes me be
bold turn my back on them abandon them
make them think this guy is so off the
pale so insane because you know it's not
for episode it's not for weeks later
they got to wait for for episode it's
just four hours later they're gonna see
me totally you know win them back and
and it's a it's just a better way to do
it I was thinking that as I was watching
like last season of orange is the new
black and this season of stranger things
and stuff that Netflix has completely
changed the way the TV is written
because that's not just a season of TV
is dropped like it's clearly written to
watch one after the other after the
other it's a 13 hour movie yeah Thank
You Jon